nous accueillons aujourd'hui monsieur
mansef la croise président du conseil
multiculturel du nouveau-brunswick
bonjour monsieur à quoi bon matin alors
monsieur la quest votre organisme
conseil multiculturel du nouveau prince
lui demande d'étendre le droit de vote
aux résidents permanents dans des
élections municipales pour quelles
raisons vous dans l'esprit village qui
est généralement acquis est généralement
réservé aux citoyens
vous voulez les tendres surtout que le
nouveau-brunswick va avoir des élections
municipales en mai prochain si j'ai bien
compris exactement vous avez
parfaitement raison le nouveau brunswick
s'apprête à accueillir des élections au
mois de mai prochain et petits les
résidents permanents ont quasiment les
mêmes droits et les responsabilités que
n'importe quel citoyen déjà qu'ils
s'installent d'une façon plus ou moins
définitive au pays
ils ont pouvons travailler qui vont
démarrer des entreprises marché des
maisons ils vont envoyer les enfants à
l'école
et lorsque c'est le temps de contribuer
aux institutions démocratiques de par le
fait de voter ou de se présenter aux
élections mais malheureusement on prend
ce droit quelque chose qui doit attendre
jusqu'à parce que la sna citoyenneté
aboutisse il peut prendre un certain
temps 85 ans où certains choisissent de
rester raison pour maintenant à vie a
pour des raisons personnelles mais
n'empêche que ceci ne doit aucunement
affecté leur engagement civique de la
participation citoyenne leur volonté de
contribuer à la démocratie locale qui
est la plus proche d'eux et de pouvoir
et à forte valeur ajoutée et
contributions et dialogue
à ce propos vous affirmer que que par
rapport aux immigrants ceci pourrait
être un argument pour attirer des
migrations vers le nouveau-brunswick est
un peu parce qu'on sait que les que les
provinces sont en concurrence entre
halle pour attirer de nouveaux arrivants
comment ça va se passer dans la tête
d'un immigrant qui va dans un esprit
d'inclusion c'est un c'était un signe
positif pour dire que l'immigration
entre autres et vue d'une façon très
égal dans la province du nouveau
brunswick ainsi on veut regarder
l'aspect de quitter la maison avec les
pleins droits
venez vous trouver une nouvelle maison
avec les prés droit aussi donc
l'immigrant ils n'ont pas pris
suivi d'un point de vue de travailleurs
mais il émigre un aperçu d'un point de
vue citoyen dès la première journée
qu'il arrive
or vous aurez fait cette proposition il
y a les mêmes propositions pratiques qui
ont été faites dans les années
précédentes
est-ce que vous pensez que la voiture va
avoir un peu plus de succès cette fois
ci est alors qu'on a débuté ça fait six
ans qu'on y travaille avec différents
gouvernements que ça soit gouvernement
conservateur par la suite le
gouvernement galles en libéral et
aujourd'hui avec le gouvernement
conservateur pour dire si ce
conservateur c'est c'est la politique
c'est comme l'agriculture ça prend son
temps et bien évidemment c'est du timing
avec les avec un peu d'eau qu'un petit
peu de soleil et puis beaucoup de
travail et de labeur on peut aboutir à
certaines le changement législatif ne se
fait pas d'une journée à l'autre
c'est quelque chose qui peut prendre son
temps alors ce gouvernant progressiste à
voir des signaux très positifs dans une
province que l'immigration n'a pas été
le sujet de l'actualité pendant
longtemps on parlait toujours de
croissance démographique non plus on
n'est pas des migrations en trop donc
c'est certain c'est un gouvernement qui
n'en parle d'un discours dutronc c'est
le grand moment qui crée pour la
première fois de l'histoire le ministère
de l'immigration dans la province du
nouveau brunswick c'est un gouvernement
qui se dotent de stratégies à économique
pas en se basant sur l'immigration pour
pouvoir aller de l'avant et sortir de ce
marasme économique créée par une
pandémie est affecté le monde donc on
avoue que possible et on pense que si on
veut pousser un petit peu et créer un
premier et un précédent faisant de ce
gouvernement le premier dans l'histoire
du canada a donné le droit de vote aux
immigrés en permanence ça se fait en
frais l'histoire pour pousser dans ce
sens là il ya aussi le parti libéral qui
présente qui va présenter demain un
amendement pour dans ce sens ok là on
comprend que le parti libéral il est il
épaule et les autres partis c'est quoi
leur position je comprends que deux
partis le parti vert est 100% d'accord
c'est un parti qui a toujours démontré
l'inclusion de la part les décisions qui
prend au par le leadership etc
le discours d'un dialogue donc c'est un
parti bien évidemment
qui est pour cette motion en tant que
tel j'ai parlé avec des membres de
position en tant que tel et je dire ils
veulent aller dans ce discours de
création de dire des inclusions par le
projet de loi qui compte déposer mais je
suis aussi en conversation avec deux
gouvernements
parce que si on s'est bel et bien on est
prêt si nagui 306 un projet de loi dans
un contexte un mouvement majoritaire qui
vaut aux patientes rôle
ça doit avoir une certaine unanimité
mais évidemment un support du leem donc
j'étais en conversation avec avec le
ministère la semaine dernière et se
contentent ce serait de vraiment
travailler avec le gouvernement en place
et que toute la halle la chose
rationnelle et désarmement faire en
sorte de voir si le ministre allait bien
évidemment en l'intention de considérer
cette piste et pour de quelle façon
qu'on peut faire l'histoire ça alors là
on parle des élections municipales en
arrière-plan vous pensez que on pourrait
étendre ce droit aux élections
provinciales et fédérales non je prenne
de bataille depuis les dernières six
années a toujours été le gouvernement le
plus proche du pain donc le gouvernement
municipal genevois genevois a nullement
pour quelle raison des citoyens qui sont
propriétaires ou locataires citoyens
actifs et engagés dans une communauté
qui leur appartient - l'immigration l'a
toujours été
will juridiction fédérale mais ça se
passe dans les communautés et les
meilleurs moyens de rétention et
d'inclusion et intégration de la
province du fédéral je crois que les
communautés doivent se doter davantage
de pouvoirs pour pouvoir s'identifier je
veux dire et pour pouvoir se prononcer
attentats la matière de l'immigration et
lorsque je me fais un cheval de bataille
c'est lorsque je vois le plus de valeur
ajoutée et je reste très confiant que si
jamais on pousse un peu que ça soit un
faisable jeudi gibert et là dedans le
plus de valeur ajoutée niveau des
provinces où l'adhérent ça c'est une
question et nous disent qui merci
beaucoup monsieur moncef loi quoi je
rappelle que vous êtes le président du
conseil multiculturel du nouveau grand
saut merci beaucoup merci à vous ça a
été un plaisir